et je suis actuellement avec Yann
chanterrel bonjour bonjour vous êtes
aussi intense socialiste des Français
établiors de France une séance de
questions actualités qui a commencé par
un échange assez tendu entre le
président du groupe écologiste au Sénat
Guillaume Montard et la première
ministre Elisabeth borne autour et bien
de la proposition de loi à l'Assemblée
nationale du groupe lyode pour abroger
la réforme des retraites la première
ministre est restée ferme elle l'a dit
il faut combattre ce texte car selon
elle il est inconstitutionnel sur le
plan financier votre réaction à cette
réponse de la première ministre bah ma
réaction c'est comme depuis le début de
l'étude de ce du texte qui a été adopté
c'est véritablement le coup de force
permanent une forme de déni démocratique
puisque il y a jamais eu de vote réel à
l'Assemblée nationale et on voit bien
que le gouvernement fait tout ce qui
peut il utilise tous les artifices voir
d'ailleurs à la limite de la légalité
parce que ce qui se passe à l'heure
actuelle au sein de la commission des
affaires sociales et particulièrement
inquiétant véritable coup de force où
les étudie même pas les amendements qui
sont proposés par par l'opposition et
donc qu'on comprend c'est surtout que ce
gouvernement a peur d'un vote pourquoi
ils ont peur d'un vote parce qu'ils vont
le perdre ils savent qu'il y a pas de
majorité au Parlement sur ce texte c'est
ça qui sont en train de démontrer en ne
voulant pas que le Parlement discute de
ce texte et votre surtout réellement sur
ce texte vous parlez de courte force et
pourtant le gouvernement s'appuie sur la
constitution l'article 40 sur la
recevabilité financière des propositions
de loi elles ne peuvent pas aggraver la
charge publique or cette proposition loi
du groupe et bien elle aggrave la charge
publique de 15 milliards d'euros c'est
quand même assez assez conséquent alors
après il y a aussi le président de la
commission des finances qui lui est
jugeant la première voilà et qui lui a
donné son feu vert donc on a vraiment un
problème aussi d'ordre institutionnel
quelque part derrière ça de pratique
politique de quoi a peur le gouvernement
de laisser les parlementaires faire leur
travail et de voter sur un texte parce
que vous dites ça n'est pas valable au
motif de l'article 40 mais il y a plein
de propositions de loi de ce type là on
en a même voté une hier sur les bourses
justement pour les qualités de manière
unanime pourquoi il n'a pas été
d'évoquer article 40 moi je me pose la
question donc en fait c'est un
subterfuge de la part du gouvernement
pour empêcher qui est un vote de
l'Assemblée nationale ça c'est très
clair mais par contre ça ne va pas
empêcher des mobilisations à nouveau
j'espère massive le six juin prochain
pour justement montrer au gouvernement
que on se laissera pas faire ça ne sera
pas fini au moins minimalement tant
qu'il y aura pas eu réellement une
onction démocratique par rapport à ce
texte sur le fond est-ce que vous
reconnaissez que ce texte cette
proposition de loi du groupe liote et
bien même si elle est adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale elle n'a pas
d'avenir politique car la majorité de
droite ici au Sénat la rejetterait alors
après vous connaissez le circuit
c'est-à-dire que le Sénat rejette ça
peut revenir à nouveau à l'Assemblée
nationale et c'est l'Assemblée nationale
qui a de toute façon le dernier mot donc
après on va voir aussi une provision ça
dépendra de la décision mais par contre
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir ce
que va décider l'Assemblée nationale à
partir me manque elle n'a pas voté parce
que si elle vote contre le signal qui
est envoyé quand même est assez terrible
pour le gouvernement
le signal est terrible et je pense que
le gouvernement qui s'entête doit
prendre en compte le rejet massif dans
la population et qu'elle n'est pas de
majorité politique de le pays pour
justement approuver ce texte
[Musique]